this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much rebecca and it's a
real pleasure to be able to speak with
you here today at least virtually and i
just want to say before i start i have
several connections to cornell
that make this especially meaningful to
me i first of all grew up in new york
state
so i love visiting the cornell campus it
it makes me feel at home
i'm also personally supporting the
university financially
uh my son is a junior at cornell and uh
one benefit is i
i got this awesome jacket
let's see it's a great layer today i
have to say
uh so that's a perk and uh but most
importantly
there's such a great extensive faculty
at cornell in plant sciences
that i've been actually hoping to visit
my son and spend time talking with
people there
on a deeper basis um but uh the the
pandemic has hindered that of course um
but i know people
like dan classic and greg martin from my
postdoc days
and uh lived across the street from eric
richards for a time and they're just
so many great uh faculty members at
cornell
so i'm honored to to be invited today so
what i want to talk about
is how we work at two blades in
particular about putting science into
action
against crop diseases and so to frame
that up i want to give a little context
by putting crop disease
in terms of food systems and crop
production
how disease fits into that the gap that
two blades works to
address and the challenges to the work
that we're trying to do
so um let's see
first of all i i want to say that
agricultural production has really
scaled phenomenally
we can start here and say how well since
the beginning of mankind
and the growth of the population to
today of
over 7.5 billion people agriculture has
really kept up
for the most part with feeding all of
all the people on the planet
and this has been due to on the one hand
increase in land under production
and the use of things like fertilizer
but also in no small part to genetics
but we know that there are challenges uh
we know that the top population will
continue to grow
uh leveling off at around 10 billion
before
uh it's it's done increasing and
that most of that growth is going to
happen in africa
and as the population grows we know that
the
available land for uh agricultural
production is not
increasing so that means that we have to
grow
more food on proportionately less land
and feeding
more people at the same time so there's
a connection there to crop disease which
is
it's suggests a trend towards
sustainable intensification
and that can mean using land to grow
crops
at a greater density which is a
potential for
disease to spread throughout there
there's also an opportunity
as we think about increasing population
because africa
where most of that population growth is
occurring or is expected to occur
is also where most of the world's poor
and ultra-poor are
today and we know that agricultural is a
really significant tool
for reducing poverty
other production challenges climate
change uh
in some parts of the world it's expected
that changing
climate and temperatures will have a
positive impact on yields and
in temperate areas but also negative
impacts on yields in more tropical areas
a crop disease connection with climate
is the fact that we know that
because of climate change engines have
been moving they've been on the move
uh sarah gurren co-workers have showed
that
since the 1960s in fact fungal pathogens
have been moving from the equator
towards the pole
at a rate of three kilometers a year so
that suggests that there's
emerging threats new diseases the new
areas
it's also of course concerning to see
crop losses
in the areas that are already struggling
to feed their populations
and they're going to be hit by this as
well
another challenge in the world in food
systems is the problem of abundance
versus
scarcity so this is a calorie map of the
world caloric intake and you can see how
distinct it is in different areas in the
world
today 820 million people go to bed
hungry
every night we have a significant amount
of hunger
we also have up to two billion people
who suffer from micronutrient deficiency
and a significant chunk of those are
children and the impacts of that are
going to be on
stunting and wasting which will impact
them the rest of their lives
so today we have issues compounded with
the other issues i've just mentioned
at the same time we also have issues
with
over nutrition if you want to call it
that diseases
like obesity and overweight becoming a
real plague especially in wealthy
countries
where you have high clark intake but
ironically also
in some poor areas which are switching
their diets now and are quite
susceptible
to issues of non-communicable diseases
from obesity and heart disease and so
forth
now the connection here with crop
disease is that because
these non-communicable diseases are
enormous problems significant problems
for health care
that they receive a lot of attention and
priority
in countries like the us and that makes
them a priority for funding
another challenge is from food waste and
loss
we've heard the figures that 30 percent
of all food
is lost in the form of food waste which
seems
like a travesty of course to throw away
30 percent of what's produced but when
you take a look closer
as represented in this graph what you
see is actually there's
two situations two
real causes underneath it in the
left-hand side in the industrialized
countries
you can see that the losses are
primarily at the consumer
where a lot of food is thrown away and
much less of it
is to do with production in the yellow
box at the bottom
if you look at the other end of the
spectrum in the poorer countries
it's quite the opposite so
i what you have here is um in terms of a
connection to crop disease you have an
assumption perhaps in wealthy countries
that
uh we're producing too much we don't
need to produce as much we're throwing
away
food can't that food be shared or saved
and it deprioritizes support
for plant breeding and innovation and
production in general
but you can see if you look at these
four countries where most of the losses
occurring
in production or in handling and storage
it's a really different set of problems
and and crop disease is also a factor in
trying to secure the crops
so in summary crop diseases
in my opinion are a significant and
under-recognized threat
to food security and overall globally
we lose about 15 percent on average
uh of production to crop diseases
but that's an average and individual
diseases
can cause seven eighty percent losses
even total crop failure
and here just three examples uh
of course late blight of potato is the
granddaddy of all
crop diseases we all know about the
irish potato famine
and which the late blight
outbreaks of those years in the 1840s
were a major contributor
to famine and starvation there
uh but it's not just something in the
past we still have new strains and
outbreaks today in
bangladesh in the us it's an ongoing
problem
soybean on the other side is a case of a
top 10 commodity crop which is
susceptible to asian soybean rust which
can cause losses of up to 80 percent
and it's a huge user of fungicides
and wheat which represents 20 percent of
the global
calories and protein is threatened by
different rusts
stem and stripe rust in particular can
cause catastrophic and chronic losses
and many of the varieties are
susceptible and can cause losses
uh over 50 percent and and it's a really
significant crop
for food right up there uh with rice's
most important food crop
these losses have impact large
economic impact globally uh these are a
couple specific diseases
and the kind of animal annual losses
that
they are reported to have the fao
reports that
in total annually about 220 billion
in economic loss is caused by crop
disease
it's also a problem for smallholder
farmers and smallholder farmers are
defined by farming areas
of less than five acres or two hectares
and um
have it backwards don't i uh sorry small
farms anyway
and the average annual income uh
under about twenty five hundred dollars
a year
and supporting about five people per
farmer so in total
affecting about two and a half billion
people on the planet are
fed through smallholder farmers
but smallholder farmers don't
necessarily
produce a small contribution to the
world's crops they can be
up to 80 percent of the work force in a
country
they also can produce up to 60 to 80
percent of some of the world's crops
such as rice
cassava and millet and those are all
done on small
five hectare farms and
smallholders have fewer options than
large commercial farmers
they may not have access to resistant
varieties
or chemicals to control diseases or if
they do have access
they may be too expensive or they could
be not stored correctly
and so these people are particularly at
risk of hunger and food and security
you can imagine how devastating it could
be if you're someone who's just barely
producing
enough for yourself and your family to
lose
10 percent of your crop would be bad and
certainly 70
would be devastating
so how what are the practices to
mitigate disease of course there are
some
first off good management practices and
prevention
making sure as much as possible you have
good soil health
is is fundamental using tools such as
crop rotation inter-cropping good
sanitary measures
barriers and so forth are ways to reduce
the amount of crop disease
chemicals are a major tool that
agriculture uses the crop protection
industry
is is very big for a reason chemicals do
work
um chemicals of course can
be uh become less effective over time
just as well as resistances
can um but still we use them they're an
important tool
in the toolbox of protecting crops in
fact annually the world spends over
15 billion dollars on crop protection
chemicals
but still it only partially is effective
controlling diseases and that's on a
large scale on a small scale
you have farmers out there trying to
protect crops as well
there you can see in these images that
they don't always have access or know
how to use protective gear correctly or
to store chemicals
so it's not a perfect answer
another tool of course is genetic
resistance
and crop reading itself as a science got
started in the early 1900s with sir
roland biffin and in fact he was
breeding for disease resistance
so uh in the grand scale of history it's
a relatively young discipline
but he made major contributions as did
norman vorlog
uh to focusing on conventional breeding
for
rust diseases of cereals
and really these three different methods
are all
important measures to control crop
diseases
two blades were really interested in
genetics in particular and so i'll be
talking more about that
and you can imagine how much science has
advanced since the time of biffin
and even borlaug uh science at places
like cornell
and also at the sainsbury lab where we
do a lot of our work
has massively increased our
understanding of plant disease
and plant immunity and that
understanding of the mechanics of the
interaction
is so important to create meaningful
disease resistance
and i'm just going to highlight a couple
of key
actors here in our molecular
understanding and that's on the one hand
the pathogen-associated molecular
patterns pamps
are fragments
of pathogens that are recognized on the
cell surface
by receptors called prrs or
pattern recognition receptors and these
recognize the presence of pathogens and
initiate a response called pti or
pam triggered immunity to trigger
defense responses
and there are also internal receptors
the nlrs
or nucleotide binding site leucine-rich
repeat proteins
which are receptors for
effectors that are introduced into the
cell by different kinds of
pests and diseases and nlrs recognize
the presence of these effectors and
trigger eti or effector triggered
immunity and the general
contribution of these two is they work
together
this is still an area where the
knowledge is continuing to be extend
expanded
but from the disease resistance
perspective
what we generally think of is that pti
can confer
broader but less
high level resistance in crops so it can
recognize
multiple species and provide some level
of resistance but not to the same level
as the race specific resistance that's
conferred by
nlrs but that is very specific so
they're both useful in breeding
and that's just captured here in this
slide that shows
soybean on the left and green beans on
the right
and you can see that the soybean is
affected by asian soybean rust but it's
a close relative with bean
and the bean is unaffected and
of course from our knowledge we expect
that
this is conditioned now by the presence
of nlrs and prs
in in one plant and not in another and
of course much of conventional breeding
has aimed to
identify these resistances and
introgress them
and that process has increa improved
over time with tools like molecular
markers and and so forth but
a potential limitation is that maybe
resistance isn't always present in a
crop
and you might want to look more broadly
as in this example i'm showing here
to other crops where you might want to
um introduce resistance
and it's not interfertile and so you
would
engineer resistance transgenically and
there's been a history
this is an outdated table i put together
a while back
but it makes this point which is there
have been
lots of examples of engineered
resistance of different kinds
in a number of crops into the field and
greenhouse and so forth so there's a
history of showing
this but a poor history of getting those
results
to market and really it's only since the
1900s or so
the 1990s where some
disease resistant crops reached market
squash
and papaya and they've been around ever
since
uh and in all that intervening time
there's been only one new
uh transgenic resistance that's reached
market in recent years and that was uh
resistance
to late by simpla so
this shows you that there there's
there's a gap that exists and this is
really
where two blades comes in we um
want to address this gap and our ability
to
come into this pro into this problem
uh was really initiated by roger
friedman our founder and chairman
uh roger has spent his career as an
advisor to david sainsbury
and david's charitable organization the
gatsby foundation
and between roger and the gatfey
foundation
they established the sainsbury
laboratory in norwich about 28 years ago
which was explicitly focused on
looking at the molecular plant microbe
interactions
between plants and pathogens and so
roger has had the
vantage point of seeing the science
develop and seeing that gap in
translation so
he and i worked together uh prior to
establishing two blades but he invited
me to come and
help him set up this idea of two blades
and we have a small but excellent team
of people
and one of the things that characterizes
us and what we try to do is that we have
a combination of experience in
science and business
and when we started two blades in 2003
this was pretty much the
the landscape we knew that there was all
this new knowledge about
plant pathogen interactions and genomic
tools and and so on
uh but it really wasn't getting into
agriculture and
so we established two blades to bridge
that gap
and successfully take those advances
and create long lasting resistance
and coming back to this image we draw a
lot of our knowledge
and expertise from from understanding
this area and how we exploit
and translate that into our mission
which is we are a non-profit
organization
and we uh functioned in two ways to
bring that technology forward on plant
disease
to benefit food security and and we have
a two-pronged approach a two-pronged
business model
we work on commercial
disease resistant targets with seed
companies
uh and we also separately or not always
separately
best of all as if it did both
we can affect disease issues of
smallholder farmers
in developing countries and in the one
situation
we will do this essentially at a fair
market rate we'll earn income
and uh that will help to pay for
programs where we're doing it for
smallholder farming and we expect to
give things away and there we're
partnering with other
government agencies and charitable
foundations and
this came together essentially as a new
model for advancing science for for
broad benefit
so what exactly do we do we set up
programs of research where we can see
molecular um a basis
for conferring resistance uh and have
the right partners
and can can have a feasible approach to
a disease solution and we advance that
we do that by keeping a product
development focused
so think about what's going to be
feasible from a
product point of view uh in essence
we're like an ag biotech company
but we're we're non-profit and we
support the projects that we take on
with
project management support we undertake
the business development aspects and
contracts
we manage intellectual property where
there is some and where
it's not serving just the project at
hand we also do technology licensing
in in-n-out licensing we support
contract research and
of course we have to support these
programs with funding
so in this process of translating
science to the field we have a lab group
at the sainsbury laboratory embedded
there
and this is a great environment not only
is it part of our stable
of uh related enterprises
uh between two blades the gatsby
foundation and the stansberry lab were
all kind of
united through uh david sainsbury
but this has been a laboratory that's
been very successful
at producing fundamental knowledge in
this field so it's a great place for us
to have a laboratory embedded there
and provides a rich environment
we so we have a group there we also
collaborate with a lot of universities
and public research
organizations and this is just a little
snapshot of our
our network and um in addition to the
academic and
the kind of science end of the spectrum
input and collaborators
we have the kind of the delivery
partners which are large and small
companies
as well as members of the cgiar
and overall we have partnered with
about 20 universities 28 companies and
the four cg centers in about 16
countries
and this represents just our contractual
partnerships
it doesn't get into our informal
networks too but
it's a great great collaborative
environment and
people seem to appreciate an
organization that's trying to
create benefit uh for all of agriculture
and and so everybody has been super
cooperative at trying to
work within the various programs that
we've been running
we've had great support from uh
funding initiative from from the gatsby
foundation and david sainsbury
but that's been leveraged now with other
grants and with business income and so
forth
so here are some of the solutions that
we've produced
to date uh we've addressed some of the
major unmanaged diseases
of major crops using different
approaches some of them
um and uh transgenic some of them
uh otherwise with different kinds of
strategies
and i'll get into that in a little bit
of detail in a moment um
also another activity that we've had is
along the way we've
need to develop new tools for doing this
work better tools to
work more efficiently and that's led us
to new methods for cloning resistance
genes
uh we actually working through disease
resistance with some of our partners
uh we came connected to the tal effector
code and talons is a genetic
platform that came from santa bonus as
many of you uh probably know and that's
been a great tool for both gene editing
and for
coming up with strategies for gene
regulation and
uh just to kind of have a momentary
aside
on that um to exemplify how we approach
things like in property and enabling
technologies
so in this when we learn about the
talifector code it turns out the uh
scientists uh at martin luther
university who had discovered it
thomas lehigh and sebastian shornock um
they had the responsibility to develop
their invention themselves at that time
the german patent law uh was
it didn't go to the university first of
all
they were not sure how to exploit this
invention um
and and they could see and we could see
that it had tremendous potential we were
grateful that we learned about it from
them
before that they published and so we
worked together with them
and what this graph is showing
uh this figure is showing that from
their invention
what we worked out was that we split the
rights exclusively so the two blades got
the plant rights
and the inventors kept the non-plant
rights and then we worked together
to get them out into broadest use and so
uh
with one partner thermal fisher formerly
life technologies
we licensed all of the rights for
non-plants which commercial
applications gene therapies and so forth
together with uses and production of
reagents
both for non-plants and plants so that
they could make
towel molecules available and two blades
retained the commercial plant rights
and we undertook a process of
non-exclusive licensing
and kind of a unique model there we had
a series of licenses that we did with
small and large companies
it was scaled based on the size of their
sales basically
so that it was a fair market value for
each level and we had a very simple
licensing strategy
had upfront fees but no royalties or
milestones and
in this case and in all of the way we
operate with industry
we have grantbacks of rights for two
blades to use all uses
at our discretion for developing
agricultural applications
so in terms of programs we've taken a
common theme throughout
and though there are many useful uh
tools in the breeding toolkit all of
which
we endorse and are needed we focused in
on
one and that's really to create
multi-gene stacks
and we do this because we understand
that you should never bet against the
pathogen
single gene resistance can be
short-lived it can be overcome in a
single season
so we want to try to reduce the odds
that a pathogen can
evolve to overcome a single gene
resistance
by not only pyramiding our genes but
combining them into a single locus
and that's why they want to segregate in
further breeding and
become ineffective but keep that stacked
together
to ensure that we produce durable
resistance
and i'll talk about one specific example
the work that we've been doing in wheat
stem rust
i know there's a lot of activity in
wheat stem rust at cornell so
i try not to go into too much background
here i know you're familiar with it
but uh of course wheat stemmerist was
something
a problem that was solved uh in essence
by norman borlaug back in the 50s and
and
central part of the green revolution
variety is resistant to stem rust but
unfortunately
these varieties were overcome the
resistance was overcome in 1998
first in uganda by a new race of the
pathogen
and ultimately this race spread and
mutated further
to 13 different strains
of stem rust in
over 13 countries throughout africa and
into the middle east
and represents a major major threat to
wheat production
worldwide
there's been progress on finding disease
resistance in a number of wheat and
wheat relatives
and increasingly more and more genes
have been cloned from these different
sources
and two blades has been interested in
trying to
amass a bunch of these different genes
to put together into multi-gene
cassettes and in this image i show
four nlr genes represented by the little
hook image coming from these different
sources
that we've worked together with csiro to
put together into a multi-gene cassette
together with another
apr resistant adult plant resistance
gene which is a
hexose transporter to make an initial
stack
and that's what this looks like it's
nicknamed
big5 and this stack
was put together through
a combination strategy in a low copy
vector
that was uh developed by michaelis and
colleagues
and and they have been able to produce
an array of gene stack constructs
through this method and this is uh
one i'm going to talk about in in more
depth um
but they've also been able to produce a
whole series of these
and big five is about a 37 kv
insert that's that's pretty big that's
why it's difficult to make these stacks
but making and colleagues are able to do
up to seven
or more genes up to 60 kb inserts
so this is a great technological advance
so the big five stack was put into a
wheat variety
and that was sent to minnesota with our
colleagues brian stephenson and
co-workers there
to do some field testing and this just
shows the field testing
process getting it out into the nursery
and doing some inoculations and ratings
it always is exciting to hear brian
stephenson talk about it he was
so excited about the results in fact he
said he had to name a new category for
raiding this hypersensitive resistance
because he hadn't
seen zero symptoms of
stem rust before
here's a bit more depth on the results
from those field trials with the big
five stack
and what you see here are
percent of planned infection
of the susceptible controls null lines
and the parent lines
over two seasons blue and gray are 2018
and 2019
compared to our multi-gene lines which
really were
clean uh not showing any uh symptoms at
all
and then these are some of the single
trans genes
individually tested and uh
you do see different levels of disease
here with different genes
sr22 and sr50 really have very low
levels and you can see that reproduced
here on the leaves in the images
themselves
and the apr which is generally sort of
an intermediary phenotype
you can also see that in this image
now because you can see that not all the
genes are
providing resistance completely
individually that suggests
that it's not quite as strong as we like
and in fact we do consider this
a first stack and not the last stack in
particular
an observation that happened while we're
working on this is that a new
[Music]
new strain showed up in sicily
that overcame even more of some of the
resistance gene some of which were used
in the stack
so this was tested against our
big five stack and while we can see that
the stack itself
was resistant to this race if you take
it apart into the different
individual lines some of them hold at 32
for example
but we lost three of the five there and
so that's certainly not
the leading product we want to take and
develop as uh
something put in them in the field so
we're going to keep working
on putting together more stacks and and
really trying to make sure that we have
this nailed
and possibly in future being able to
trade in and out genes
as they may become overcome individually
results were just published last month
in nature biotech so if you're
interested
in that you can read up on
on that and just to
make a quick statement that central to
this work
was some of the cloning work by mcaliff
also on the pathogen side i didn't
really go into details but
peter and melania really focused and did
a lot of
work to understand the effectors and
which ones were really critical to
virulence
and that's a really key component to
understanding these stacks as you can
see how
quickly they can become overcome and a
number of others
uh branda for identifying resistance
genes
and the work of brian stephenson and
colleagues in particular
i'm going to switch now to one other
example and and just
close out shortly with a couple of other
examples
um before i take questions but one of
the other pathogens that we've worked on
quite a bit is asian soybean rust
it's uh something again that we put a
lot of effort into understanding the
pathogen side of things and what
effectors are critical
and this one's been challenging because
it's an enormous genome
and it goes to a lot of different hosts
so there's all kinds of
recombination and things going on giving
it a lot of
variability but we took a similar
approach
looking at where we can find resistance
and in soybean itself there's not a lot
of resistance
and those have generally been overcome
in their use in the field
so we're looking more broadly across
various relatives
to soybean this one is skijana's cajun
or pigeon pea
it's a pretty little plant and uh we
knew through
our collaborator sergio brahmanchenkel
at uh in brazil that he had populations
of
kajanas that were segregating could
segregate
for different symptoms of the pathogen
and we
hypothesized that in there was
potentially an nlr gene contributing to
resistance and
we went out for map-based cloning and
indeed we found a gene an nlr
that we call ccrpp1 and when you put
ccrp1 from kajanas
cajun into soybean we can see
very strong resistance there
and this is work done in our lab in the
sainsbury lab
in conjunction with sergio's lab in
brazil and together with an industrial
partner in this case dupont pioneer now
corteva
with the idea that they will take it all
the way through to
product development and with other
resistances again keeping an eye
on the durability we've since also ended
that program with them and we've started
another program
with uh monsanto now via crop science
uh so we continue to work on this
pathogen
and then just more briefly a couple
others here's some bacterial resistance
we've worked on xanthomonas
bacterial spot of tomato have
demonstrated in numerous field trials
that the pepper gene bs2 which is an nlr
introduced in its close relative of
tomato can confer very strong protection
and double the yields of tomatoes in a
number of different backgrounds
another bacterial disease we've used in
this case a pr protein
efr and when we put that into tomato we
can confer protection against ralstonia
bacterial wilt which is a pathogen for
which there is not a lot of genetic
resistance in
any crop really in tomato and also in
potato
efr was introduced into potato and shown
to protect against rostonia
efr has been put into a huge number of
crops including more recently tree crops
we see protection in citrus against
citrus canker
anzylella and in apple
against erwinia so it's a good example
of how prs can be
more broad in their resistance
but at a more intermediate level of
resistance so it makes a great
combination
within ours uh
lastly i just want to talk about one
other program that we've supported
we haven't driven the science in this
case but this is work to
engineer late blight resistance and oh
my seat
in potato and this is work driven by
mark elaine
at the international potato center in
nairobi and
he's done a number of trials with a
three nlr gene stack
that show very tight resistance and
improvement in yields
and uh is close to the market we hope
within the next few years
and and we expect this can improve
smallholder farmer income by
up to 40 percent so this is exciting to
see this one move on
also working with mark has been a great
opportunity to
um get to
an understanding some of the regulatory
considerations
in africa in the us of course we have a
working framework
but this is not always the case in a lot
of african countries
and although it's sometimes a shifting
landscape
some countries move forward with
biosafety regulations and
then they may step back overall the
trend is showing
i think you can see that more countries
are adopting frameworks is a
increasing level of green just over the
past five years
so what are the challenges we face i've
mentioned some of the technical and
regulatory issues
even in a country like the us where we
have a clear regulatory process
it's extremely expensive and
finding better ways of trying to
develop uh these resistances is a
priority
and a challenge how we deliver these
resistances for smallholders is a lot
less straightforward
than trying to do it for commercial ag
where we can have a partner
and they can take it all the way through
to market
adequate funding is a major issue as i
mentioned
within there a lot of the funding
as we know it as planned scientists goes
towards biomedical research and trying
to get attention to some of these plant
science issues
is still a challenge and that
recognition of crop disease in general
is is a challenge still a lot of people
don't appreciate especially
in countries that have adequate income
to spend on research
that these are important issues
in fact if you look at the sustainable
development goals or the copenhagen
consensus which
ranks threats and where investment is
going to benefit society the most crop
disease is nowhere to be found
um but i was gratified uh in 2019 to
hear bill gates
make the statement that pests and
diseases are among the biggest
challenges that we currently
face with our global food systems uh and
and that threats intensifying with
climate change so maybe we're beginning
to see
some more attention shifting to uh these
problems
i'll just point out that here in this
picture uh next to
bill gates is david sainsbury who's
certainly been one of the long-term
supporters of this kind of research
so even though they're these challenges
and we keep trying to build a pipeline
of resistances
that we know are effective uh because we
feel that it's the most
environmentally benign way to uh
benefit human health and the environment
having these
particular impacts
protecting harvests and and food
security against chronic and
catastrophic losses
ensuring that you can still make gains
in productivity in low-income countries
where
ag is so important how we face
climate change and ensure that there's
resilience and we maintain our
productivity
and how we do this all with doing
more with less as really as part of the
challenge that we face today
and this really connects to a lot of the
sustainable development goals
so that is where i will stop for today
and happy to uh to take any questions
well thank you so much to yanna um
that's really such a fascinating model
of research and and development
and i'm wondering um i can't see
if anybody has questions feel free to
type in questions um
if you have them um and
also you know don't don't be shy just
type up
or raise your hand but meanwhile i just
wanted to ask is you have a way of
um comparing the the fundraising
approach the model that you mentioned as
a way of sort of mobilizing resources
into r d
as compared to conventional academic
work is it somehow easier to to
move product financial product and
outcome
product that this way or is it tougher
would you say
i'd say it has the advantage that it's
diversified
and i you know unfortunately especially
in the us
i think that the number of sources for
funding for research is pretty limited
uh and i'm sure
i don't have to tell any of you that
writing a lot of grants to the same
organizations is kind of a small
pool uh so we have the advantages in the
fact that we can tap into other
resources
we have been able to get grants uh from
different kinds of foundations
and in the one case of um the citrus
research and development foundation
which funded some of our work that we've
done in citrus
we felt that we had an advantage a
little bit of an advantage there because
they were really trying to solve a
problem for industry
and we were a little bit more industrial
like
and that i think gave us potentially an
advantage there
but we also have the ability to generate
business income
and we do some philanthropy it's a very
very small
amount of of the work that we do it
certainly doesn't
really help us to fund programs because
research is expensive
but it's the diversity i think that
helps
okay great anybody else have questions
or comments
i'll slip in another one while we're
waiting for people to
uh get their thoughts into words um any
comment on how
about the maze stuck in ear rots
what what ways forward do you see on
those yeah so
yeah i didn't i didn't go into depth on
that one apologies
trying to keep it uh snappy
um so just to comment on that that was
another program that we did with
monsanto
because those are important targets
disease targets for the us
uh they produce significant impacts on
yields in the us so they were keen to
have some
tools to to fight those diseases and
that was a program that we did for about
five six years
and uh established a platform actually
that one was kind of an interesting one
because we
were using a pr platform as opposed to
the standard
nlr uh kind of approach and
that program wrapped up and and we
brought it to a successful conclusion
with them and so now it's up to monsanto
to move some of those
outcomes from our work through their
product development pipeline
um but as i've spoken with you we also
hope maybe we can leverage that platform
to address other needs in corn
particularly for smallholder issues and
so
that's why i was interested in in
hearing your perspective about what can
we do in terms of
the mica toxin producing fungi and
developing resistance there
and and the other part of that interest
that we're looking into
is to make gene stacks for fusarium
and um aspergillus but also for striga
which is another one that
would we think could potentially be
interesting for
holders and and we hope to be able to
benefit from the
transgenic pathway that's already been
initiated there
it was initially started for drought
tolerance
in africa i actually got a boost because
it has bt in it
and so it has insect resistance uh
secondarily but that turns out to be
very effective against fall army worm
so those plants are going through the
regulatory pipeline
now and and that will help i think make
a pathway for
us to maybe bring some traits in corn
but we'll see that's
great paul
paul would you mind going ahead and um
go ahead and speaking your words or i
can also
speak for you if you prefer unmute
okay i don't know if you can hear me yes
okay thank you thank you so much for
your presentation
i was wondering what is the level of
involvement of the governments
where you work on and related with the
problems that they have for example in
africa as you said
yes so it's i have to say for us
we have not had the opportunity to be
really actively engaged
directly in that but some of our
partners like sip
working in in east africa and the
short version is it's hit or miss it
really
varies depending from one country to the
next
uh and i know that mark's regulatory
strategy in trying to get his late
flight resistant potatoes to market
he has to sort of update periodically is
it going to be kenya first
is it going to be uganda ethiopia where
can we see this
going as it's moving ahead and
uh sometimes you see um
some countries are supportive and then
they may have a new advisor that
or a new change in government and that
progress
towards biosafety laws may revert
you know that that gets sidelined for a
time so it's
it's pretty hit or miss i think that you
find
other countries in other parts of the
world south america i think is more
embracing
of biotechnology um asia
some asian countries are now i think a
little bit
more open to that so it's it's a work in
progress
definitely and ricky had a question
that's allied something
about building trust um for the
technologies rick you want to go ahead
and
weigh in there yeah i was just curious
about your
um perspective uh just even for
the genetic engineering technologies
which have a higher threshold
of acceptance culturally across all the
different you know backgrounds that you
interact with
um is there a certain method that
uh either you or uh groups you
collaborate with
find more successful in that it's more
uh like a demonstration kind of
technique or uh
you know trying to build cultural
relationships
because even something that's uh
conventionally bred that may be
a slightly different color than a crop
that they're usually used to
can be just as rejected as you know
as anything else so i think it's a
really important thing i just want to
get your perspective
absolutely no it's it's super critical
actually uh you know from the planning
stage initially
you don't want to create something
that's not going to have a good chance
of succeeding
and you have to be very culturally
attuned to
um what it is that people really want to
buy and has
a good flavor you know those fundamental
things of what they eat
and things like cooking time so if you
make a variety that takes longer to cook
that requires more
fuel and so there's all kinds of
cultural considerations like that
and for us i think really the key there
is to having
the right regional partners who
understand those kinds of considerations
and also allowing them to
really star in the work they have to be
the ones who pulled this technology
don't want to
push technology there has to be some
ownership and
need and value for it so that really
comes out of the kind of partnerships
you form and and foster
okay well we are actually technically
out of time now
and i don't see any more questions
posted oops joel
how about donald giving john luther the
final word
okay sorry i posted it to the wrong
place first um
okay so in your answer to to rebecca's
question it seemed like there was a lag
you were working with
monsanto it seemed it was a lag between
when developing
or developed countries were getting the
benefit versus when
you know sub-saharan african countries
were getting the benefit
and i wondered if you know there could
be a mechanism to force
monsanto which has tremendous expertise
in getting this stuff to market
force them to help you to get the
benefit to the
to sub-saharan african countries in
tandem at the same time
as when you know it hits the us
or whatever yes well uh
we we prefer rather than trying to force
them to coerce them
and and that's really not hard as it
turns out
the issue fundamentally of course is
that it's a business
and businesses have shareholders and
they expect to make money
uh so if they're spending a lot of
research dollars and things that aren't
going to contribute to that bottom line
that's sort of an issue for them
but they really want to do it in spirit
and
uh we've found that so we have special
features that we have in any of our
agreements that we get to have the
benefits back of our research for
developing country applications and
they're very happy to do that
and they've generally been excellent
partners are really supportive of the
things that we're doing and
we hope maybe in some point in time
the soybean resistances that we have
we'll be able to work with them
to make them available for small holders
and the corn work i just mentioned
we hope to work with monsanto to help us
deploy
uh those lines because montana's been
involved in that wemma
corn that i was just describing a moment
ago so they're they're able to and
especially if you can come
with third-party funds for example uh a
usda grant a usaid
grant then that eliminates the the
problem for them
and allows them to to cooperate because
they really want to
uh you know i think there's a very
strong interest in and scientists at
monsanto just like elsewhere that they
want to see
the benefits of the work they do um
okay so i promise to make that the last
question but i'm thinking of reneging by
first off welcoming anybody who needs to
go please do we are over time
but there is one more question and if
matthew wants to get it off his chest
i will be stand behind and wait
thank you both um i just i wanted to ask
if you have any opinions as to how
moving forward we can balance you know
using
these really exciting genetic
engineering technologies but also keep
in mind
that we want to maintain crop
biodiversity and that crop biodiversity
also impacts
you know pollinator diversity and there
are a lot of ripple effects
so do you see it being very difficult to
kind of achieve the balancing act
yeah that is it's a really excellent
question i don't think we've learned how
to deal with it yet
globally uh you know on the one hand
there's a lot of advantages to
monocultures and whether or not
you use transgenics in them or not it
actually is more efficient if you have a
uniform wide acreage crop
it's all requiring management at the
same times and harvesting and all of
that there's a
efficiency that comes with monoculture
which
helps to make the costs lower and and
that's just a fact of life that we
have to work against to think about how
do we
achieve the diversity that we need we
know that when we're putting
for example from a crop disease
perspective you put out a big crop like
that you're
you're putting out a buffet essentially
for one pathogen just to come in and
show its way right through and that's
bad
uh it's also bad for other reasons like
diversity
so yeah globally how we find a balance
between wanting to be able to be
efficient producers and
keep the balance of diversity
it's not a question i'm able to answer
but it's certainly
one that we want to address in future
and and diversifying diets and
all of those things diversity is is
really important
but at least for intra-specific
diversity as applied to
you know our mutual interest in pest and
disease management
the facility which with which transgenic
methods allow you potentially to use
multi-line
type cultivars is at least a you know an
advantage potentially right
you're not getting you know it's not
giving you dietary adversity necessarily
but it would give you that
genetic diversity pest squelching yeah
more more easily than many other ways
might do you know
still there we have the issue to do with
the regulatory burden so every time you
want to introduce a new
cassette or something you have to go
through the regulatory process
again and that's expensive i'd love to
see
in future ways that we can have a more
science
focused regulatory process that that is
a little bit more refined and less
expensive but still just as stringent
and is also faster so if we can
get these traits into the field safely
and more quickly and less expensively
then then we start to be able to be more
responsive to disease in more real time
as well
and to have that kind of diversity that
you mentioned okay well
please join me in thanking our speaker
diana thanks so much again for a great
presentation
and thanks to everybody in the audience
for joining us for this
first of the semester thanks well and
and hopefully i will get back to cornell
sometime
and uh would love to connect with people
anybody who's interested
please do get in touch okay perfect
thanks so much we look forward to your
in-person visit
sometime soon thanks rebecca thanks a
lot
bye-bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu